eux aussi montre les crocs pire ils s'en
servent au grand désespoir de certains
habitants de joué-lès-tours des chiens
errants attaquent et tuent depuis un
mois des moutons des poules des lapins
une centaine d'animaux au total est pour
l'instant la meute court toujours le cas
chopin la nuit on dort pas beaucoup mais
quand on entend les chiens aboyer je me
lave vittore habite la campagne de jouer
des tours il y a quelques jours ces
bêtes subissent les attaques de chiens
errants
bilan deux moutons tués et un autre
gravement blessé
pourtant l'homme est catégorique ces
chiens ne sévisse pas à cause de la fin
mes agneaux qu'en l'état la tête
arrachée la tête elle est là le corps
aussi mais manquait rien saha paquet
pour manger vous ça a vraiment tué pour
s'amuser pour tuer assez beau chien que
j'en veux c'est six ans un propriétaire
c'est aussi à lui que j'en veux comme
victor et dans le secteur ils sont
nombreux à déplorer des faits similaires
lapins moutons poules
en tout plus de 100 bêtes sont mortes
depuis le mois dernier trois chiens
responsables ont été identifiés dont un
meneur un puissant animal semblable à un
malinois catherine habite à la croisée
des lieux des attaques
aujourd'hui elle mène une enquête et
seuils d'alerté autorités et riverains
sur ce danger
légalement il ya pas de solution le seul
truc assez de faire les signalements
si on voit les chiens ces chiens là
quand ils vont venir s'amuser à faire
leur raid des capus de beta a tué il ya
des joggeurs il ya des cyclistes et tout
le monde parle des enfants parce que
barre des petits trucs qui couvrent
voilà un chien pour enfants pour le
moment les habitants n'ont d'autre
solution que la prudence
tous redoutent un jour un drame causé
par les chiens